Neil: On the day that the Super Bowl was played,
do you realize that's a bad day to be a
chicken?
Chuck: Wings and things!
Neil: I'm just saying.
Chuck: Okay, so what what of stats do you have for us?
Neil: In fact, any day in America is a bad
day to be a chicken. Americans consume on
average about a million chickens per
hour. The chicken is the most
slaughtered animal in all of the history
of agriculture.
Chuck: Wow. It's a good thing that I don't have any feelings
for chickens, becuase they are delicious and I just
blame chickens for being so delicious, so
it's not my problem. So how
much chicken is consumed in the form of
wings, because the Super Bowl is
probably the day that more wings than
any other day in the world.
Neil: I know so all these, like, sort of you know, wingless
Gary: Wandering around,
Neil: Walking around, definitely walking.
Gary: We have an exclusive interview on Playing With Science.
Chuck: For the people who can't see, but a rubber chicken, and once he heard
Neil's stat, this is what he had to say.
Rubber Chicken: *Exhales in disgust*
Neil: Turn that face towards the camera. Look at that face!
So I got another another related statistic.
Gary: I don't think that
chicken could take any more.
Neil: So in the United States, we consume 8500 whole
chickens every 30 seconds.
Yes, we consume 8500 chickens
every 30 seconds in the United States.
Chuck: You are horrifying my friend.
Neil: Alright just more data for you.
Chuck: I love it!
Gary: Well I was waiting for you to say I'm going to digest those numbers, but we're going to move on.
Chuck: Very cool, very cool.
listen to podcast on stitcher radio
itunes podcasts google play music
soundcloud and two men new shows
premiere every wednesday night at seven
p.m. eastern subscribe now and don't
miss a single science filled episode oh
we just not just went out to plot baby